foreign
[Music]
you two have written together yes this
is I'd love to hear about that sort of
your your first of all how you came
together to this story and then also
what your process was like as a writing
team sure
um well I think that like the idea of of
writing something together sort of came
about organically over the years we
started by acting in a couple projects
together and that was like our toe dip
into do we enjoy being on set together
and you know we've talked so much about
the rental already and that was our
first time working together in this
capacity with Dave directing and me
acting and that was just
such a fulfilling experience for both of
us even though I was not a writer or
producer on the rental I really felt
like a collaborator with Dave and like a
real support system for him there and
I've never felt more comfortable on a
set until this movie I think
um just because I trust Dave so much and
I know you know I've been able to watch
for so many years the care he puts into
everything he makes and I knew he had
such a strong vision for that and
watching him write the rental with Joe
Swanberg is sort of what inspired me to
start writing and I wrote horse girl
with Jeff bana and spin me around with
Jeff baino which were actually thank you
um we were writing spin me around and
this simultaneously during the pandemic
so basically after the rental it just
sort of felt like a no-brainer to kind
of like oh we should write the next
thing together because we're already
right here and it feels so nice and we
we actually had the seed of the idea for
this at the end of 2019 teen and we were
like when are we gonna actually have
time to sit down and do this and then
three months later the world ended and
we were like if you remember at the time
everyone was like all right it's going
to be locked down for two weeks and so I
was like all right we got two weeks to
write this thing and so you know I was
waking us up early we were writing all
day she was getting a little irritated
with me and um and but we pumped out the
first draft in two weeks and then had
forever to refine it
and what was the seed idea was it of
someone going back to their town and
yeah I mean it came about when we were
actually walking through my hometown in
Northern California and we were walking
from my high school to my mom's house
and I think just being in that setting
you know these ideas of going home and
reconnecting with your roots and kind of
confronting who you used to be compared
to who you are now and how you feel
about all that it just kind of made its
way into the story
I think that we sort of started with the
genre we love the romantic comedy space
and we wanted to kind of just try it and
then our weigh-in was through the
characters and I feel like all of the
themes in the movie sort of revealed
themselves to us even as we were writing
it you know I think at the beginning of
the writing process we were like we're
gonna just make a classic rom-com and as
we were kind of like just following the
character's natural dream we're like but
it's more gonna be like we're Trojan
horsing in like a female empowerment
story about like women connecting and
figuring out who they are and really
it's like an adult coming-of-age story
like by the time we were pitching it it
had kind of morphed into this other
thing but I still think we retained the
elements that we wanted to from that the
The Nostalgia of those ROM comes from
the 80s and 90s that we love and then
kind of I think also because we're such
rom-com fans and I will watch rom-coms
over and over and over they're my
comfort movies
the tropes are so familiar people who
love rom-coms know the tropes and that's
actually great because then when you
know the rules it's easier to break the
rules I mean that's what I love in this
is it it all the tropes are there but
then there are these darker elements
that creep in or I mean you just
consistently make some very very bad
choices and you know it's it's it's
great to see kind of the stakes escalate
in that yeah I think I think with both
of the the movies I directed like if you
look at the the synopsis on the page
they they might feel familiar where you
might think like oh I know where this is
going but then within the execution is
where we try to bring something unique
and like she was saying it's like we we
use what we know and love about these
different genres to almost lead the
audience on a certain path and then try
to pull the rug out from under them
every step of the way and keep you
guessing I also just feel like there are
even though Dave's two the two films
he's directed um are in vastly different
genres there's a lot of similarities at
the core which is like that Dave is
drawn to doing these relationship
stories right these deep dives into
really grounded characters and then sort
of like putting them in as he said like
kind of familiar situations in the
cinema landscape but being like but how
would how would you actually react what
would that feel like like let's just
make it all complex and messy
I you know I wanted to you mentioned the
the female empowerment story that
smuggled in and I wanted to ask you
about your scenes well the cast is
incredible and Kelsey Clemens is so
fantastic in your scenes with her
um really provide a cool through line in
the story like outside of the rom-com
elements right I mean it's about sort of
what you find in each other could you
talk about working with her on in in
that part of this story definitely
Kirsty is incredible she well first of
all that character I think that was kind
of the main that was like our first big
detour when we were laying out the
characters in The rom-com tropes and all
this stuff and we were like okay so the
character of the Bride is usually either
kind of like bright-eyed and naive
um or like us shrew you got a hater you
want the other characters to get
together and we sort of just thought
well what if she's like cool and great
and low-key our favorite character in
the movie and how does that make
everyone else react you know
um where I mean that's just that in
itself throws a wrench in everything
where her character is coming to break
up a wedding and then all of a sudden
she meets the bride and she's like I
like you this is like this is making
everything so complicated and when you
think about when you think about love
triangles and a lot of movies it's
usually two people going after one
person and in this one it goes all
directions yeah anybody could end up
with anybody but also you know there is
this thing where my character is really
identifying with her character right she
really represents the person that Ali
used to be the way she used to see
herself and so you know over the course
of the movie she finds herself you know
in in her digging that comes from like a
sort of sinister manipulative place she
actually starts to realize all their
similarities and want to protect her you
know when it comes back around to
everything that's gone on with Sean they
have to have this big Reckoning of all
the things that they didn't get closure
on from their relationship and that was
us wanting to explore this theme of like
the one that got away and what does that
mean when people break up with people
and get back together why do we have
this Nostalgia for those people
um are we actually missing like a period
of time in our lives and not necessarily
that specific person like a big part of
the plot right is Ali kind of her whole
misconception about that first night is
like oh I only feel this way when I'm
with you not just like oh I'm out of
touch with a part of myself that could
still exist and to bring it all back
around to your actual question Kirsty as
an actress
um is so incredible
you know she brings a really
unexpected energy to the role and I
think to everything she does we're huge
fans of her and like
I think that was part of it is like her
inherent coolness measured against my
inherent nerdiness
was just right and and truly as an
actress like she's so present which is
also true to the character and she's
always like
I don't know some people have you know I
don't know what I'm trying to say like
it's like I just think she's very
surprising in her choices and that
chemistry was so new and perfectly
fitting for what these characters are
going through where like she was always
kind of unsettling me in a perfect way
for those characters versus other people
in the film like Danny pootie who I feel
very comfortable with and we should you
know yeah definitely give it up for
Danny uh we we you know specifically did
that and wrote that role for Danny so
that we could lean into that chemistry
in history as well yeah
the scene of you and Kirsty sitting on
the bed when you're talking to her and
she's just taking you in it looks so
great on this big screen like she's so
still and it's just her eyes as she's
taking you in it's a beautiful moment
are you capturing what you were talking
about I think that like very different
energies from both of you and just the
way she takes you in and everything you
say in that moment is is really
beautiful definitely she has so much
quiet power to the way that she acts and
that's so the character right is that
she's so confident that she's like I
don't have to compete with this person
I'm just gonna hang out with her and
kirsty's like that way there's so much
bubbling beneath the surface
um could you also talk about Jay Ellis
who's also fantastic in the film I mean
huge huge talent and he was sort of what
how did you cast him yeah so I mean this
this role um it was it was really tricky
to cast because
you know
um all of these characters are are
flawed you know they're they're making
questionable decisions but at the end of
the day we wanted them all to be
redeemable still because they are good
people they're just going through it and
so with with Sean we we needed someone
who you just inherently like and Jay has
this quality that you root for him no
matter what he's doing and I think part
of it is that he's just so grounded and
real and human and so even though again
he's he's doing things that are not the
most morally sound things you can like
see where it's coming from and you can
hopefully relate to that
yeah he was fantastic uh okay and not to
go through every single person in the
cast but you would love to security yeah
Julie
write that role with Julie Hagerty in
mind but with no idea whether we would
get her for the role but you know it's
like when we're writing stuff we have to
Picture People sure but you can imagine
her first read and she's flipping
through and she's like huh I will say
talking to her on set she said to me she
was like I found this incredibly
refreshing she was like you know at my
age I never get sent material that has a
lot of sex scenes in it and she was
really excited a woman after my own
heart
she was only on set for three days and
we fell we all fell in love with her to
the point where like still texted with
her constantly she's like our other
mother truly yeah she's amazing and
Haley Joel Osment too I thought was
I I mean we wrote that for him too he
did okay
that's another role where
on the page it's probably like the most
comedic role
um but we wanted someone who who
wouldn't like lean too far into the
jokes we wanted someone who was like a
good actor who could just kind of
inhabit that goofy you know whatever and
you can imagine like
tonally the movie is kind of unique in
that we have these comedic moments that
are sort of very much tonally like our
sense of humor and some of them are a
little dirty and you know on the page I
think that was the most difficult thing
when we were
selling the movie was kind of like
trying to describe what the tone would
be to people because because on the page
it might move they're like the cat is
and puking on this plane is
this like a broad comedic set piece and
then I'm spewing it all over people on
the plane and we'd be like but
understated right grounded
from an emotional place
um it was like so it was really fun in
terms of all the actors coming on board
like having those conversations with
them like even Haley who obviously yes
is such an intelligent actor and being
like but don't worry it's gonna be
actually we do want you to fill out and
and in that way I realize I'm not
finishing a lot of my sentences but I'm
getting somewhere
um you know with all of the actors we
did have these deep backstory
conversations because it was really
important to us that every character had
a rich backstory even if it's one line
of dialogue you know Danny referencing
his recent breakup with Talia or you
know Jay's adoption story or things like
that even even with Haley who you know
he's kind of a clown for most of the
movie but
um when he's making his speech at the at
the wedding you you kind of realize like
oh this guy is a great family man